[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time
i'm rhett and i'm link this week at the
round table of dim lighting
a decision has been thrust upon me and
my family
thrust and before a final decision is
made
i want to use this forum to talk it
through
because this is no light decision
this may want be one of the most
difficult decisions
that we've ever made as a family and i'm
teasing this
as if people who listen don't read the
title
of the podcast and they don't know what
i'm talking about maybe some people just
the title being something like should
link get a cat
yeah yeah should link's family get a
kitten
which becomes a cat and that's the first
point
yep uh but that didn't shut it down so
there's been a whole conversation
uh and i'd like to bring it here to the
table rhett well i've got lots of
thoughts oh my gosh and yeah and i did
some research for you i just want to let
you know
oh really i did some research
boopity boop uh this may turn into one
of those podcasts where it's like i'm
just
i'm airing out all of my my inner
turmoil and getting your opinion on it
because before we get into that i do
have something else that i'm
i'm grappling with that i don't think
will take that long but are you using a
grappling hook
it's bothered me um
no i'm just using self-analysis okay
and when i when i share the story i'm
going to share with you
with my family i didn't get i didn't get
the response i wanted
i got i was like oh my gosh am i
am i a creep before you share that do
you want to acknowledge
the nature of our conversation last week
i think we should just
quickly as you know things
got deeply real
uh one episode turned into two we are
recording
this episode before that episode part
two
of the conversation uh was is released
so that means that we haven't seen what
you think about it yet how you've
responded so
we're going to but it's been a week
since you've listened to it if you're
listening as these come out so we
anticipate that
that you you've weighed in on the
conversation using
your biscuits which if you haven't it's
not too late
as always use hashtag your biscuits to
uh
to be a part of this conversation right
and we don't know
i mean we could continue the
conversation we could just have a
follow-up but we just didn't want to do
it
until we kind of hear your thoughts on
it yeah so
i mean we're open to continuing the
conversation
uh publicly in some form or another if
if that if if the public discourse
uh calls for it if not we'll just move
on
um it's not like we haven't we didn't
continue to talk about it yeah for two
more hours we talked about it after that
podcast
and we're still good we are still good
we're still good we were good and we're
still good
don't worry about us that's right we're
about yourself but you're not making eye
contact
okay but that's too much i don't know
because it hurts my neck okay okay
my next kind of look i like to look into
my actually i don't ever look into my
camera
you probably look into that camera a lot
uh if you're a camera you're a camera
looker
yeah i'm not a camera looker yeah i'll
look into that camera if i want to
emphasize
my opinion on something you're saying i
mean non-verbally i wonder how many
times i've
actually looked into the camera that's
filming me i don't believe
that it's mini i go through life looking
for a camera to
communicate with non-verbal true we can
we can have a conversation about that
that's another one yeah
um i get this is kind of this first
thing is kind of related to
well cameras a little bit i mean my kids
are well into
uh school and like i open the door
and they've got this screen and there's
like all of these kids
with their with their faces on the
screen and it's it's so weird
to be doing class over zoom
i'm not doing it and i really hadn't you
know
really hadn't experienced it i mean it
extended my kids don't start until next
week by the way it's really late for
school all right is it like hey
we're in class from 8 o'clock until 2
p.m
pretty much yeah i mean with one
continuous
and the require no it's not that you got
to go to different teachers
uh high schoolers yeah i mean lando
doesn't but shepard's gonna have the
same teacher the whole day yeah
lando's got the same teacher there is
one class that switches out
and i haven't asked him exactly how that
works but i mean they've got scheduled
in breaks and like
he gets up and moves around i mean i
heard some banging in there
and he was like drunk class he was doing
pe he was doing calisthenics
oh wow in his bedroom i was like okay
with the camera on
yeah like he was following along with
like the uh instructional thing
but that's that's tough but the thing i
realized was well
i mean we've been conducting so much of
our
business and like teamwork and
coordination and meetings
on zoom for months and months and months
now but
that's totally different than being in a
class
but we did get a taste of it
whenever i mean as a company we're we're
doing a class
you know i don't want to get into the
specifics of it but it's just pertinent
to say
in a totally different mode than how we
conduct our business in in business
meetings over zoom
we're all attending these enrichment
classes
right so we're all basically students
for that one hour every
week or every other week and that's as
close as i feel like i've come to
what it feels like to be my kids in in
school and remote electronic learning
and something happened there that i
observed that
uh i don't know it just disturbed me a
little bit
on reddit there's a thread called uh am
i the
[ __ ] where somebody posts something
that happens to them and how they
contributed to a situation
and the the question up for debate is
was i the [ __ ] in this situation and
the best ones are the ones where the
title
seems to like spell out what i did
makes me an [ __ ] but then when they
describe it the really good ones
change your mind because of the details
my question to you is
yeah yeah you were the [ __ ] am i no
it's
it's a slightly different question it's
am i
the am i a creep okay here's what
happened
we we were in one of these you were in
it too we were both in this
uh class of sorts
and i know where you're going with this
by the way but i'm not going to say
anything
okay you got to tell me okay all right
here's what happened i you know i
debated whether to talk about this
because i i it was very i wanted it to
be clear up top and hopefully i've made
it clear
if any of our employees are listening
that this is a different venue than
and i'd i haven't done this with
know what you're going anybody say and
yes i have done it okay so i'm looking
at the screen and like
okay you know it's like it's a class
your mind i'm i'm paying attention but
it's just somebody talking and there's a
they'll usually put a a presentation
slide up
and the thing with the slide is you can
read everything on the slide
like that but they've only read through
half of it so i'm like okay i know where
this is going
i've read the second half of the slide
yeah so what am i going to do now
i'm going to look around at the other
people and see if they're paying
attention
and i noticed that one person who was
sitting
you know with the webcam on we all
basically all had our webcams on
by the way for my kids they're required
to have their webcams on
okay you just can't you can't turn it
off and say that you're paying attention
of course which means you can't just
like put a sheet over yourself in class
same principle and put it on my privacy
sheet
one of your kids got in trouble for that
like you had to say it was your idea
yeah it was a tarp a privacy tarp
i noticed this one person um
in the background like they're sitting
in the foreground right in front of
their webcam but in the background over
this person's shoulder
i see some one of the far walls is
decorated with
albums i'm like oh i did that in our
creative house
okay and then going in a different
direction so oh it is
so then i went over and i pinned this
person and i made them full screen
so i could see if i could identify their
albums and so i'm looking over this
person's shoulder
happens to be a woman to me that's not
pertinent
but you did mention it and i'm gonna see
if it might be i'm looking over her
shoulder
at her albums and i'm like i don't i
don't and i'm like leaning in you know
i'm like i don't recognize any of these
albums it was like and then she's like
what are you looking at
that's not how it works in 2030 that's
how it'll work i'm like
i that's i recognize that harry styles
album the one with watermelon sugar on
it okay
you you're really narrowing it down
whoever this is is going to know who it
was
yeah maybe that's why i shouldn't be
talking about it it's it's someone who
works for us
who is a woman who has albums in the
background no it's not
it's not someone who works for us it's
someone who works for the
company the company that's putting on
the class i do not know this person
that changes this this person does not
work for me okay
that's important to me because then as
i'm
looking at these albums my eyes move
over a little bit
and there she is and i'm like
right oh my gosh this this feels creepy
meaning i i'm starting to feel like a
creep and i like
unpinned her and i like i was like oh my
gosh what have i done
who who am i because it felt weird that
like i was like scrutinizing
this person's decor but then i'm like
that's borderline cree i mean people
could pin anybody they wanted and just
stare a person down
that's what i did and that you okay
you please take the heat off me and tell
me about this i knew this is what you
were gonna say
it went a slightly different direction
so and
and it's interesting that you found this
ability
like more it seems more recently well i
know you can pin people
no no you pin people who aren't talking
you begin to
and don't know your practice this
uh i think this happened pretty early on
um
for me in the in covid
and uh but i
my motivation for doing it which is
we're in a big meeting and everybody's
listening
and uh i i click on people so i can
see if like if they seem engaged
if they're like processing something is
this a meeting that you're
leading uh i think the first time i did
it was in a senior staff meeting that we
did is
right it's just i'm kind of just
sometimes i'm like this person's talking
about this
does this person who isn't directly
related to this
uh i'm i'm i'm i'm asking the question
of an employer
of a boss it's like yeah you are are
they engaged it's a valid question
when you're when you're if you're
sitting around a boardroom table which
we normally do with our staff
i would look at a person who's like is
so-and-so
listening to so-and-so and should they
be like i'm i'm thinking things like
that right
yeah and then more recently with the
training classes
but hold on with that boardroom you're
telling me that you pinned someone who
was listening to someone else talking in
order to analyze
if they were engaged yeah and then did
you
feel a pang of creepiness this is the
analogy that i use
okay so
sometimes i go on a walk at night right
and and go up to people's windows and
i'm walking
there are some houses that like
the big like biggest window in the front
of the house is into their living room
and you can see what they're watching on
television oh i've done this
i don't stop walking you don't stop
walking do you not usually
you know if they're watching something
really interesting you don't like square
up
turn your shoulders no but you know what
happened the other night was walking
and i looked into somebody's living room
basically what i'm saying is
when you've got your blinds open at
night it's permission
your living room is like your my
understanding is you're saying yeah you
can look at my house
and that's how i felt ultimately about
the album collection i was like
this person set up the shot yes and they
framed it so
they framed the shot so everything set
dressed their own zoom shot everything
in the frame
is fine for people to see because
they've set up that shot now i don't
feel that way about the bedroom window
you know i'm not a peeping tom i don't
go to the side yard and look into that's
off limits
but i'm in the street like i haven't
left the sidewalk i'm not in your yard i
may slow down i slowed down the other
night because
i passed the house and i was like
what is that they're watching on
television oh this is a new one this
show
and i was like
they have a security feed of their
driveway
on their television and that's why i'm
currently on the television
yeah are you serious yeah it's not that
exciting
did you it is that's crazy and then
and now boy did you wave uh no but now
every time i walk by i'm like there's
the house that's got the security feed
of the driveway very prominent in the
uh in the living room facing back
were they seated in there watching it no
it's just constantly if they're not
watching television they've got a
security feed
of the driveway on the living room
television i can do that
well i could probably do it too you just
a contest you're competitive man
no i'm not just saying i'm saying with
the nest cam you
and their group google calm crashed you
can cast
you have the capability of doing that
like if i have if i'm expecting guests
sometimes i'll put it up there
they must always be expecting guests
it's hilarious
that you you stopped and saw yourself
but here they're on their television
here's the thing though here's what i've
concluded they know this is how it works
because why would they leave the window
open and have the television where you
can clearly
see i actually think it's suppo it might
be for like intruders it might be like
anybody who comes into our driveway will
see themselves in our driveway
that we are seeing on the speed because
what you would put it in like a
different room if you didn't want people
so what i'm saying is
yeah yeah that zoom window in a video
conference
is your public facing window and so i
feel
now if i'm just like i'm going to click
on this person and just
look at them which is not what i've done
just watch them to watch them i don't
even know why i would do that and you
know but
see what it feels like to be creepy for
the training exercises again
you like you said we're in this class
and this is a night and we'll probably
end up talking about what the training
is later we're just
in the early stages of it right now uh
this was our idea
it was our idea for everyone to go
through this training and i
am thinking like uh is this are they
getting
are they getting what they need out of
this did they see engaged oh so you do
pin
you pin other i pin multiple employees i
i
and you could tell by the way i told the
story that i felt comfortable pinning
someone i didn't know
who i was taking a class versus pinning
someone who worked for me
i think if they heard that i'm just
afraid they would be creeped out i don't
pin them for an extended period of time
i like because you can't see everybody
right so everybody i can see if they're
like oh this person
but if it's like that person looks
mad or that person looks disengaged i
might click on them and be like am i
getting the right impression from them
right now and it's not and
it might be a five second five second
checking in
like okay all right but they they looked
they looked mad but they just
are just they you know are you do you
feel
and again i'm i i'm i'm really on the
fence i'm
i'm i'm legitimately asking do you feel
okay about this because you're the boss
and there's like a professional
motive associated i would feel fine if
they did it to me i thought that i was
gonna need to develop some sort of
approach of like
okay i'm gonna
uh direct message this person and say
would you mind if i pinned you so that i
could see
take a closer look at your albums and
see that's
you're seeing that's worse the
difference between me and you
is that i'll just look at their albums
and feel no remorse
and you'll send a message that actually
makes it worse it makes it worse
now now that we're talking about it
confessions make all times worse but
then they provide
they relieve burdens now okay
if i had the ability i don't know how to
do this i'm sure there are people who
can do this
if i had the ability to like if i see a
message on your phone that's intended
for you
i shouldn't read that if i had the
ability i had
i was getting to hacking i do have the
ability to read a message on the phone
i'm sorry i lost my train of thought
but what i was getting at is some people
can like hack your security cameras at
home
right and like look at what you're
seeing on your nest camera really
yeah and uh i mean that's why you need
two-step
authentication but i'm sure you already
have it set up
but if you didn't and someone was able
to get into your
obviously that's a violation of
someone's privacy because they do not
they think that this video feed is for
them but when they
are when i'm on a video conference my
assumption is
anybody could be looking at me right now
i think i think we just need to send out
you're talking about the difference
between somebody being small and a memo
and somebody being big on your screen if
you got a big ass
monitor already this is a small already
big so there's a gray area here
i just think that this is your open in
fact the living room window thing
is even is not a great analogy because
if
you are watching television in your
living room and you saw a tall man
like slowly walking in front in your
front yard like looking at what you're
watching on television you'd feel a
little
violated because you're not the window
isn't open
unless you so you are watching right and
then it's well that's a tit for tat
so yeah so i just think that this is
like
this is like a window this is like a
drive-through window you open it and
of course you can look behind me you
this is my public facing window
i just don't think people
will i just don't think people are aware
of it i feel like there needs to be a
warning
maybe remember you're being you can be
watched
in full screen at any moment so watch
your resting faces
i think everybody already knows this
it's easy to forget
yeah you can you start you start
scratching an itch before you know
people are watching
and that itch could be anywhere okay
amendment to my idea
if i had somebody pinned for
investigatory purposes
i'm not even sure if that's a word and
they began to do something embarrassing
and it was clear to me that they had
forgotten that they could be pinned at
any point
booger picking you know
something more salacious whatever at
that point
i i feel it would be my moral obligation
to unpin them
and maybe even send them a message hey
you're on chat don't forget that you
were big on my screen
you were coming up big is that is that
eric clapton
on that album behind you
i would have recognized eric clapton
slow hand
um i i i also wonder should should we
send out a memo i'm not going to single
you out we've done that just saying
hey you know what employees just
remember at any moment
rhett could be you could be coming up
big for red i think we just in the
general slack the general slack before
the next training meeting
we say please listen to the latest
episode of your pistols
gosh because you should be doing it
anyway
i don't know man i i feel like i'm never
going to pin anyone again and now you're
going to be pinning constantly
yeah like how did that happen i'll do
all the pinning for the pictures
i got to tell this story i gotta throw
my son under the bus take some of the
heat off of me
uh lincoln who's 15. you know he he's
just getting started
and he at the dinner table i was like
asking about class and
how does it work with zoom and and like
he got the sheepish look on his face
that he's about to tell a lincoln story
and so we all get excited about that and
he's like well
how's him uh i don't remember which
class it was and he was like uh you know
i was
i was just i was making a noise to
myself you know like during class i was
like
[Music]
i'm like what what what
what it what is that noise he's like i
don't know i was bored i was just making
a noise he's like
it's like it sounds like you were dying
it's like that's your boredom noise
and he's like oh god yeah so i was like
and then all of a sudden i looked and i
got big on the screen
and i realized i wasn't muted yeah
that's how it works lincoln said
because everyone's automatically muted
usually in a classroom
and he said that the teacher said
we got to mute that boy
well let me in front of everybody and
then lincoln was like he was like i
i sent a private message to my teacher
and i was like i am so
sorry i thought i was on mute but i was
like but you didn't explain
why you were making the death noise if
there was ever any doubt
that uh lincoln is of your loins
you do not need a paternity test what if
i was doing that while you were talking
thinking i was muted
wow death noise i'm glad we solved that
one because now we gotta solve this cat
problem
okay but first um what are we what are
we trying to get people interested in
this week link
we're trying to get people interested in
um i mean that's an old shirt right
there
shoot shoot shoot kiko told me don't
tell me
don't tell me kiko i'm gonna remember
it's two things
the travel mug no no i may have just
revealed something
that i shouldn't have i don't know what
is it oh hair tie
you got a hair tie oh mythical hair tie
i'm actually using
uh another hair tie at the moment
just because uh they gave me something
you gotta go to mythical.com they gave
me something for a photo shoot
and what's the other one took them back
shoelaces
shoelaces yeah we got hair ties and
shoelaces we're expanding around here
because you don't need to use shoelaces
to tie your hair and you can use hair
ties
shoes that would be tough uh we have
both mythical.com
rep your boys on your feet and on your
head and everywhere in between
before things go out of circulation like
this shirt which is one of my favorites
can i ask you one question before you
get started about this yeah yeah yeah
i mean the timing of this is interesting
right
uh i know it is because just the other
night not the other night the other day
when we were at the creative house you
know our kids both both
all of our kids have taken to
using the creative houses they're like
like i don't know like their getaway and
like
lock will be like dad gonna go to the
creative house today
i'm like uh
okay and like he hasn't even started
school yet
and i'm just like wait why do you like
going over there it's like i just like
to get away
yeah it's like exactly have a play just
you know you get to go to a house
yeah you know so lily has come over a
number of times to
do some work and uh when she came over
the other day she was like
hey rhett i think
we might get a cat or i think i might
get a cat
and she was obviously trying to
instigate something a conversation
yeah but i assume that she doesn't for
her own good listen to this podcast
she doesn't know about my encounters
with the cat she doesn't know about the
soft place
in my heart that i now have for cats no
right lily
lily is um is has taste and
like she listens to dear hank and john
you know you're right she's okay
she's too smart for her she knows what's
up
so so it's just so you're just saying
this is even this makes it even more
interesting you're just saying it's
serendipity
it's potentially destiny she knows your
reputation of hating cats she doesn't
know the update
wow um because you're bringing this into
a very different environment
if you had to brought this proposal
into rhett from two months ago i would
have a completely different but my
you're talking about cats has changed
because
because you had a cat you had a run-in
with cat
that you that you gave you gave your
love to this cat and now it's gone
and presumably did i mean people got
upset with me some people got upset with
me that i
presumed it was dead but listen just the
other night
you know right before i went past the
house and saw myself on someone's
television
i went past the cat house
we always go past there still no cat
still a sign
up still lost the cat's not coming back
has your heart grown
i gotta say that i'm like man what are
the chances i can find another cat like
that
you know that was a highlight of those
walks now i do have the ability to see
myself on the television which is i
definitely go by that house every time
that's a highlight now
uh which is just kind of a substitute
for the cat
but uh no like it's funny because it was
getting to the point where
because all these people followed up
after that podcast and we're like oh
yeah tabby's
they're called tabby's the orange tabby
right oh yeah those are those are always
really really
friendly oh you know what also a maine
[ __ ]
is the official cat of maine they're
huge they're very sweet too they're very
dog-like
and i've heard that because we've got
some friends who've got a maine [ __ ]
a lot of hair though and so yeah i'm
sure i'm allergic to it anyway
i i just you you're you're gonna this is
gonna fall on soft ears
but i will say it's interesting i have
something that might give you pulse
and that's not a pun um but it kind of
is a good one
so yeah i meant to say pause so the
other night
well lily tex lilly hardly ever texts me
you know she's she's beginning her
senior
year i feel for that's tough because you
know it's her senior year of high school
and here she is just doing it on a
screen
getting pinned un knowingly by creeper
guys
player one i'm freaking concerned
and i'm just you know i'm just a little
sad she's she's doing well
uh all things considered
but it's just a bummer you know yeah and
so she texts me and like a perk up
because i'm like you know she sent
um she she sent me a pic of of a cat
that was just it okay and then and then
i didn't know how to respond
and then i got distracted is there
something particular about the cabinet
it didn't really was it doing something
funny was it skateboarding on the second
look
it with the cat was in her lap i could
tell
when i got home i could tell that was in
her life because it was her shorts
but when i got home uh we're eating
dinner and
uh or we're about to eat dinner and this
is like family conversation time but
but she says dad there's somebody to
talk to you about and i'm like okay and
i'm thinking dinner she's like
after dinner oh okay that's interesting
oh okay well so
you all talk about oh this doesn't need
to be for the whole family this just
needs to be for me it's what i thought
and then when dinner was over i honestly
i
i've gotten distracted i've gone into
police mode of make sure all the dishes
are done
yeah that's pleasant by someone that's
not me yeah i'm i'm not
fun to live with sometimes and she's
like dad
i need you to come sit on the couch it's
like oh my god is this a freaking
intervention
and then she like she turns on the
television and she's standing
and like christy's like smiling like she
knew what was up and all of a sudden i
look on the screen
and it is the first slide of a
presentation that she has created that i
would now with her permission
like to share with you let me pull this
in here oops oh there it is
as you can see it's a a beautiful
orange hue background with white bold
lettering
and if you i mean if you're not watching
this you want to watch this
ear biscuits youtube channel every
sunday we release the video version
it's got all the visuals including this
big bold white letters
reasons why you should let me get a
kitten
and then it hits me this is a
presentation trying to talk me into
well it's pretty obvious yeah it's sort
of the thesis is in the title yeah it's
kind of it's very straight she hit me
over
over the head with it which she knows
how to communicate with dad it's like
hit him hard
so that he's not confused and then in
little letters it says
featuring yeti which i presume is a cat
i didn't know at this point or she just
gonna use like a yeti microphone
[Laughter]
and then and then down here it says
listen to me
dot dot dot i'm for real
i can be very persuading that's good
that's a really good start
i would have said i could be very
persuasive but i don't think
grammatically
you know what their ponds are on point
you know what's interesting about this
is this a thing that the youth are doing
because you know
for uh she's never from mother's day
from mother's day this year um
i told lock and shepherd i was like guys
you got to do you got to go all out i
mean like you don't do anything
you just live here and you eat and
you're here all the time you drive your
mom crazy do something cool
okay show some effort yeah and um i
remember you telling me about this
shepherd wrote her original song called
mom okay now it was just a piano just an
instrumental but it was beautiful
i recorded it uh she loved it
i think she may have cried a little bit
we listened to that
and then i was like look what did you do
and he was like oh oh
he like got this look on his face like
you won't believe what i did and then he
said mom come into the living room and
sit down and he was
casting a presentation onto the
television
and he led a presentation about jessie
and how awesome of a mom she was
brilliant so is are kids doing
presentations because that's something
to get excited about
we can complain about generation
whatever they are right now all we want
but if they're doing presentations
there's hope that's the brilliant
manipulation of it all right she knew
that you would love a presentation
yes and i mean i would venture to guess
if we went to the right realms of
tick-tock
all the children are talking about hey
kids
you want to get what you want out of
life you want to wrap your
your your parents around your finger
present something
present something to pick a font and a
color and
have at it because it gives you the idea
that your kids might one day be
gainfully employed you know what i'm
saying
right like it's like if you can do this
you can do business i mean
half dare i say 75
80 is presentation if you can do a
presentation presentation [ __ ] you
will win at life
yeah it's i mean where would we be
without powerpoint right
man okay i'm really interested
in this and i i perked up i purr
up slide two
now you see there's a picture of cat
reason number one
the cuteness factor and then on the
right there's a picture
that it's the picture that she texted me
apparently but when i did not respond to
the text
at all she was like oh that didn't work
i got to up my game and that's when the
presentation came about i didn't ask her
that
but above the picture it says his name
is yeti
yeah and it's this white kitten a few
weeks old
sitting on that's lily's lap those are
her purple pants
and then underneath it it just says just
look at it this is smart because this is
this is the cat is looking right at
right into my there are a few uh
principles in advertising that she is uh
really doing effectively here
the first one is the fact that she
exposed you to a picture of the cat
just out of the blue so this is a
repeated exposure to the idea and
you know people have to see and hear
things multiple times in order to
actually take action so the fact that
she seated
the cat earlier in the day really really
smart maybe she should go into
advertising now
she has this friend who's um
fostering kittens before they're adopted
so she goes over and hangs out with this
person and
has told me that like oh these cats are
so
cute you got to see these little kittens
and so i was aware that this was
happening but i i didn't really see this
is that cat gonna turn red orange it
looks like it's a
it looks it's it it's a white
cat with just a little tinge of
it looks like brown it could be orange
um
it looks friendly some blue eyes um
the fact she's not saying at this point
i'm like she's not saying dad
i want a kitten she's saying dad i want
this kitten it's staring into your soul
it's name
is yeti i like that name
slide three reason number two
listen anxiety is a real problem cats
can help here are some facts for you
cats lower your stress level cats lower
anxiety because they take
less effort than dogs petting a cat has
a
positive calming effect that's good
and finally 84 percent of people say
that their feline friend had a positive
impact
on their life and there's two pictures
of this we're in the stock photo
territory now but kittens
exclusively of kittens making eye
contact
again with my soul this is good
this is good so i'm not i but i'm but
i'm starting to put up walls
and thinking you might be in the 16 you
know the anxiety thing
i i just i feel like at best it's
probably a wash
there's a lot of there's a it bringing
another creature into my house
raises my anxiety i have a lot of
questions but you know what
i've made up my mind the whole question
is to the end i am gonna i'm i'm not
gonna interject
yeah and i'm and i'm gonna try to make a
demurring face
which is hard to interpret that's a
vocabulary word
next slide reason number three jade will
have a friend
this is the weakest point but proceed
studies show that it is extremely
important for dogs to be socialized
constant socialization will help jade
with her aggression towards people
and other animals so there's a picture
of jade
uh if you want more of those then go to
jade the official
instagram channel i think that picture's
on it boy is she cute
look how cute that dog is and just below
it is yeti the cat
and then there's a caption can't you
just picture them being the best of
friends
look how cute they are together and
they're not really together they're just
they've been put together on a
presentation so that feels manipulative
it yeah no she had gone the extra
mile to photoshop them together i'd be
listening but i think that
this is the problem here is i can't
picture
them being the best of friends because
i've had experience with jade
right however jade are the better
friends
but jade was better with the cat in our
vlog in my house than barbara was
the prevailing theory there is that they
were in a neutral territory for jade it
was not jade's home
but it was barbara's home and she was
freaked out yeah now i know because
barbara loved the lost cat
i can feel many listeners at this point
having lots more knowledge about
introducing cats to dogs and all the
dynamics there and picking apart
her argument i i'm not privy to that
information
so the way that i but more to come on
that so don't get too worked up
for now i'll just say there's a weakness
in her argument here with number three
because her second point
highlights a problem which is constant
socialization will
help jade with her aggression towards
people and other animals
he's basically saying jade is aggressive
she had to address this point
you could have argued listen don't bring
it up but it's such a concern it's the
leading concern so she couched it she
made it reason number three
yeah so i understand why she included it
but i think you think
that she should be a lawyer uh well
let's not get ahead of ourselves i do is
well do they do powerpoint in courtrooms
yes you could be
the thing that i'm looking for here is a
some sort of relevant fact about
um how
she just said constant socialization
will help jade with her aggression i
need to i need some
data to back that up because i know that
like uh stevie has a cat and a dog
and i was thinking about that a lot and
i'm like i think stevie does not like
her cat
well don't speak for stevie i'm not
gonna i said i think
i could be wrong uh i just know that i
know she loves her dog
i know that the dog and the cat are not
on the best of terms
but they can be in the same room well
yeah
they don't hate each other um next slide
reason number four cats pretty much do
everything themselves
another picture of a kitty and then a
picture of a
trash can with the sign litter on it
which almost looks like a coffin
they can go to the bathroom and bathe
without any helper training huh
i was like hmm that's interesting but
don't worry i'll keep the litter box
in my closet that's not that doesn't
make me feel great
it made me feel good it's like okay this
is going to be your problem
and but i have some concerns i'll get
you later okay now
i have a what might be
for you if you've never heard about it a
mind-blowing
little path that i want to take you down
that is relevant to reason number four
now we can come back to it i don't know
how many reasons there are in this
presentation i think there might be one
more the litter box
in the closet raises concerns
that i feel i need to inform you as a
friend about
all right let me get i'm gonna take you
down a path though so let me get to the
rest of this because i want to say what
my response to her was okay
so i'll go through the rest of the
presentation reason number five yeti and
i can
even make the same demonized face look
it's a picture of the cat getting
scrubbed on her neck by lily and then
it's a close-up
and her right eye is looking off to the
right and her left eye is looking a
little off to the left that's not that
this was a this is a
and this is something that like the the
clan the it clown
can do yeah can you know he's on command
and lily can do that
and it scares the crap out of me when
she does it she like looks down
and then her eyes go up and out and it's
like
it's like the demon's trying to pop out
of her brain
so she has a connection to this cat why
cause she didn't put her face on there
because she knew it would scare the crap
out of me
final slide bold letters right in the
middle that
is my pitch in smaller letters
please let me get a kitten and then i
look over at her from the screen
and my daughter who i'm she's my first
born i love her deeply
i'm super proud of her i'm i'm beaming
with pride that she has constructed a
cohesive set
of arguments and and formed it into a
presentation and and
and i just can't deny and i'm like
the way that i respond you will remember
it for the rest of her life and here's
the thing with teenagers
i'm i'm keenly aware that every time
they go out on a limb
with either to assert themselves to take
a risk
uh to share feelings you know what's
going on inside of themselves
it's it's it's always precarious because
you know i i feel like any anytime you
respond to a teenager it could
it feels like your entire relationship
is riding on it
you know well especially now because if
i gave this presentation to my dad he'd
be like
nope and then he would just walk out and
i still have a good relationship with
him but if i were to do that to my kids
the terms of our relationship maybe
they'd fall apart are
are a little different and i don't know
you can
pass your own judgment on what that is
but i you know it's
you want to keep connection going you
want to keep communication lines open
you don't they can't get everything they
want
but you have to do it in a way that it
doesn't
close them off to you because their
predisposition is to
close themselves off i i mean i'm
speaking in generalities but
and um and lily may not say that
but i i'm maybe i'm speaking less from
the reality of our relationship but more
from like fear of how it may work
and even when christy and i talked about
it later we were like i don't really
want a cat
but i don't want to make her this upset
about something she's so
passionate about at a time where like
looking for things to
you know positive things to to
experience
you know yeah i made a cup i was like i
just need to be really calculated my
response i was like the first thing i
need to say needs to be positive and
affirming i was like you know what
lily i want to commend you on making
this presentation
i'm taking the time to do it and
everything in it and i just want to
acknowledge
that if it were not for you
jade would not be a part of our lives
and that
decision for she found jade
at an adoption thing and she brought us
all over and said
i want this puppy we need this puppy
and the first picture i have is the two
of them like at that moment because
christy wasn't there and i like
texted her the picture and stuff so i
acknowledged that and i was like so
i'm gonna hear you out i was like
the second thing i need to point out is
you know and
in 10 months from now you're going to be
gone and you if if you go off to college
you're not most likely you're not going
to be able to take this cat with you
this is a family decision to have a cat
yeah this isn't hurricane this is not
this
is you guys this is you getting a cat
for 10 months or so
and then us getting a cat for the rest
of the time it's here yeah
20 years maybe and that really concerns
me
i'm also really concerned about the
impact to jade like i don't you know i
don't want jade's feelings to be hurt
well there will be at least initially
and you know soccer if there's anybody
that i spoil
you know without any argument it is jade
like i i got no defense for that and i'm
not proud of it but it does happen
constantly so i think about her and then
i'm like
i i need to know if there's if this were
to happen i'm not saying it will
i'm not saying i'm on board and all of
us have to be on board lando was there
the whole time like begging for it to
happen he's on board
lincoln seemed to be on board but didn't
care because
jade's his like he's really close to
jade he's making death noises she sleeps
with him now and he's like
christy does not want a cat christy
wants another dog well that's what i was
going to ask
because it feels like this and i was the
only person whose opinion really matters
in this situation is christie's
and christy's like i'm concerned about
the fact that i want us to have another
dog and i don't want this to keep us
from that
ultimately to where we were boxed out of
that decision
and also you know she loves plants more
than she loves
me and so she was very concerned about
the plants
because that's where you the plants eat
plants plants at my house some cats will
die
because they eat their own plants and
like you got to think about your plants
and
a plant person doesn't want to think
about their and i was like lily you need
to address the plants you need to do
research on that you need to
i need to know if there's a trial period
i need to know what it would look like
to introdu how would we introduce the
two of them i need you to do research on
that
and i i mean we have to face the fact
that like they may not get along
what a true test we have we cannot just
relegate a cat
that in 10 months you're going to be
gone that has to be isolated from our
dog
but we can't live that way but you could
go feral after 10 months
i'm like real talk we have to have an
actual trial
if this were to move forward and a
possible outcome
is that we have to give the cat back
because it's not good for the cat
or the dog or our family and you you
would have to
be ready for that so she like she went
back and did a research
she did a second presentation which i'm
i'm not going to show you
i'm not going to go through it but this
is what it looked like you can see it
here
mostly text it's just white there's
there's no more passion in it
it's just text and it all it does is
it walks through how to introduce a cat
to a home
with a dog this could have been an email
but i appreciate the effort and it's
um so we're up to speed on what it takes
step by step over weeks
to introduce a kitten to a dog to have a
chance so i
you know this is like a multi-month
trial yeah
by the time you've you've gotten through
it she's going to be off at college
but the last thing i said was lily you
have to give me
you have to address all my concerns and
you also have to
i'm interested in how you're going to
sweeten the deal she was like what do
you mean you want me to pay you
i'm like no i'm like are you willing to
make a commitment
to like watching movies with me oh
that i want bribing that i yeah like
bribe me
like i want us to watch some movies
together that are my choosing i want you
to have a good attitude when we watch
them
i want i want to i was like this is an
opportunity to force her
into to cultivate our relationship and
you need to pull out all the stops
also you need to give me carte blanche
to
exploit anything associated with this
experience
for entertainment purposes on your
biscuits yeah well that's a given
it wasn't a given because she keeps
things she tells me not to talk about
stuff all the time
like just kidding um so that brings us
to now
okay all right i'm gonna i'm gonna throw
what might be a complicating
uh wrench into this a little bit because
i'm not sure that in any of these
presentations
i can't vouch for the second one it's
very long um
if the issue of toxoplasmosis has been
addressed
uh
no it has not i have not i i may have
heard the term
prepare to have your mind blown in
preparation for that i will just say
we've gotten to a point where because
she's been so passionate about it
we're and we know what it we're very
open
to trying out this kit i think
at this point in this conversation
i'm predicting that we are going to get
the kitten
on a trial basis it has not happened
and i don't know if it will happen but
if i had to put money on it
i think that's what's going to happen
okay um i
now let me let me just i kind of like
cats let me premise this with the fact
that
again i have a soft spot for cats now
i've already told you that my
quote unquote hatred of cats was mostly
a bit
i'm just a dog guy that i prefer him um
and i did recently fall deeply in love
with a cat that is now dead
um all that being said i knew about this
whole
toxoplasmosis thing before and i'm sure
that if you're a big cat lover you're
going to get upset with me
because i'm bringing something up that
you may think is you know
unfair or whatever but it's just it's
absolutely fascinating right
and it's amazing how prevalent it is but
this people don't really talk about it
that much
so there is a single cell microscopic
organism called t
gandhi uh i don't know if i'm saying
that right but it's not a bacterium or a
virus
but it is distantly related to the
parasite that causes malaria
cats get t gandhi and the disease it
causes toxoplasmosis
by eating infected rodents birds and
other animals
estimates suggest that about 40 of cats
in the united states are infected
most don't show any symptoms but they
can develop jaundice or blindness and
experience personality changes
if the parasite spreads to the liver or
nervous system now let me explain how
this thing
works so the the theory on this
is trying to gross me out of getting a
kitten this particular organism
evolved uh it only
can reproduce in the digestive tract of
a cat
that's the only place that it can
actually undergo its
reproduction process so it's got to get
into the poop of cats
and then it's going to kind of get back
into
a cast digestive system so what it has
developed
is an adaptation whereby when it gets
into a rat or a mouse
cysts grow on the neurons inside
the mice brain and
causes the rodent to lose
its fear of cat piss so
see mice and rats they're repelled by
they
they're repelled by cat piss and if they
get
toxoplasmosis not only are they not
repelled by it but some studies suggest
that they're into it
that they're attracted to it and as you
can see that opens this mouth
well it's pee hole and it walks right
into they lose their fear of cats
essentially which makes them an easy
target which gets the toxoplasmosis or
gets the t
gandhi back into the digestive tract of
the cat and the process starts all over
again
right now how does it get in the
in the rat or the mice it because they
drink the pee poop
it's in the poop it's not in the p and
poop is everywhere cat's got poop
and the rats eat the cat poop they it
gets i mean you end up
getting fecal matter in your mouth
sometimes i mean it's just all people
this happens and if you're a rat you
probably get a lot they make it about
you
say i get rap poop in my mouth eleven
percent of people in the united states
are infected with t gandhi
so one out of every ten people is
infected
though rates are much higher in regions
where people eat more raw meat or
sanitation is poor for example infection
rates exceed 90 percent in some parts of
europe and south america
i've heard that something like the vast
majority i've heard somebody talk about
brazil
has a lot of people infected with t
gandhi now in healthy people
toxoplasmosis often causes a flu-like
illness or no symptoms at all but
it can occasionally be dangerous or even
fatal in those with weakened immune
systems
antibiotics can treat the infection
though drugs may not completely banish
the parasite now
this is where it starts getting crazy so
i i saw an article in the new york times
years ago where
somebody's talking about this basically
that
uh crazy cat lady
is a real thing right so like somebody
who lives with a bunch of cats
and has almost assuredly been infected
by t gandhi has toxoplasmosis
actually undergoes behavioral changes
because of the infection they like cat
pee and
some people say well they could develop
an attraction towards cat urine but
the studies the research on this the
data is really incomplete because you
can't really conduct
a controlled study on cat people uh in
an ethical way right but there's lots of
research that suggests
that there are behavioral changes and
let me just talk about some of these
behavioral changes that
might be the case again this isn't an
exact science
um
jaroslav fleger an evolutionary
biologist at charles university in the
czech republic is looking into
this issue he has spent years studying
toxo's impact on human behavior he found
for example that people infected with
toxoplasmosis have slower reflexes and
are 2.5 times as likely to get into car
accidents
i might already have it toxoplasma
gondii infection is thought to
alter the personalities of infected
individuals
whether rats or humans by increasing
risk-taking behaviors
studies have shown that this if you take
risks and you have a slower reaction
time
that's not a good confidence studies
have shown that this can lead to more
accidents
but on the flip side this is where it
gets tricky
stephanie johnson and colleagues i don't
know who that is but it's in this
article
showed that this risk-taking tendency
can lead to increased
entrepreneurial behaviors
so so you got to take this into account
now the crazy cat lady entrepreneur
so it gets weird but the chances are
especially if your daughter has a cat
poop
receptacle in her closet that is
that she's gonna become a business owner
surely getting on her clothes
which may become business suits you
gotta think about the fact that
she's gonna get a little potentially
riskier
and you got to be comfortable with that
and she may like be on the cover of
forbes magazine one day and thank you
but also
you're probably going to get infected i
mean only 11 percent of people in the
united states have it
if the cat never goes out and eats raw
flesh then the cat's not gonna get it
you can't control a cat you know that
forty percent of all cats have it
that's that's a low they're called house
cats you don't let them outside
forty percent of all cats that's like
almost a coin flip
globally no in the united states
it's a coin flip it's a coin flip
whether or not you're going to have
toxoplasmosis
in your in your family yeah there's your
own brain there's an upside to it
i just want you to be prepared do not
mention this to christy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
like wow you just can't be part of it
okay
especially if she's got it in the in the
closet she's gonna get it
i mean you're right the cat has to
contract it which you know
it's probably gonna happen and uh i i
know that
cat people are screaming at you right
now and i so i'm gonna you know
i know there's got to be a balancing
factor but hey i appreciate you bringing
this up
because i i will need to achieve a
comfort level on this
on this approach i am not saying listen
all that being given and like i said the
science is uh
is not super established but this isn't
like this isn't fringe theory stuff
this is i've heard of it all that being
said
uh they think that
if you take the world's population into
account i think that
more than half of the entire world is
already infected with this
with this already has toxoplasmosis so
it isn't like it's not like this that
big of a deal i mean some people
it can be a big deal uh so i'm not
and this would not preclude me from
getting a cat
i if i were to get a cat i wouldn't be
like oh toxoplasmosis i mean
i like taking risks man and now we're to
it because
i you know if my memory serves me
correctly
before lily discovered jade
and then we decided to adopt her you
said
i think we're going to get a dog you
told me that you as a family you were
heads up i think we're going to get a
dog
and then i ended up getting a dog before
you because you moved into your new
house before yeah because what we said
is
when you move into the house we'll
probably get it we had said the whole
time that we were living in our old
house we were like
this is a rental we can't have a dog
that was the reason when we buy
a house we're going to get a dog and it
was like this because you couldn't
multiple multiple year like lead up to
like the kids are like we're going to
get a dog we're going to get a dog as
soon as we move
no and so we did and i think what's good
so i think there's kind of a repeat
thing happening like you had a
connection with a cat
you've softened then lily shows up with
a cat
and by the way update on yeti uh
after the first presentation yeti was
adopted okay that's relevant
but there was another one that she was
like you know what there's another one
there's always another cat
this one's a black cat it's like oh
now we got we got luck coming in or lack
of luck
right yeah she's like this this one's
gonna be even better this one's more
laid back
this one's black this one i'm going to
call this one opal
so we're going to have jade and opal oh
interesting opals can be many colors but
the most valuable color is black
she said anyway i think you're going to
get cat well
so this is really i'm dying out of
courtesy i'm just i'm just giving you a
heads up that like
you know what's gonna happen well the
dynamics are similar here's what i'll
say
uh my family
everyone but me really
wants another dog and has wanted another
dog for a long time and i want another
dog
and uh i like the idea but
i don't know i i feel like i'm the only
one in my family with a real
grasp of the negatives that come along
with having another being in the house
right and the poop
we don't have we don't really have much
of a yard right we've got a little like
artificial grass
in one spot and that's where barbara
does her business and barbara's a little
dog
you're going to double the business
jesse will like be put but
pictures of like um
a huge giant sheep dog like sheeple
doodles or stuff like that like
this just looks like a teddy bear i'm
like can you imagine the size of the
turd
all i can see when i see that dog you
see cute
giant teddy bear i see giant pieces of
[ __ ]
now that's what i see that's not the
case with a cat
so right but i mean
i don't i to me it's kind of an
adventure i you know
it breaking the the seal on having an
animal in the house was a very rewarding
experience
for me and you know i'm so glad that we
got jade
i have positive experiences with cats
i'm i'm curious i think it would be
really cool if they could be friends
again i'm if they can't this i don't
think it will work
and then i'm like i think we could still
get another dog i don't i don't know
it's gonna be like a
a farm eventually a farm that only has
pets that's kind of
fun though can i can i read you a list
of names
uh these are famous people uh some
people are dog people and some people
are cat people
and if you feel like you're connecting
with the people who have determined been
determined to be cat people
maybe that's a sign that you should
go go the cat way or maybe you should
just stay the dog route
yes yes you can read me this list martha
stewart
what what's the question do i like
martha stewart
you you identify martha stewart you feel
like there is a
like a kinship with her spirits in some
sense
like you could vibe with her because i'm
going to tell you whether she's a dog
person i wouldn't
i would have said no but in seeing all
of her collabs
with snoop dogg
she's changed my mind and now i'm gonna
at the last second i'm gonna say yes
i could have a connection with martha
stewart martha stewart
is a dog person oh speaking
of snoop dogg
snoop dogg would i connect with snoop
dogg yeah
i'd love to yes ironically
snoop dogg is a cat person what
okay so now i'm 50-50
and but jade is like a cat that's a
confusing thing john lennon
john lennon i'm a mccartney man no john
lennon
is a cat person
see and i don't think i in my mind i'm
like if i don't like somebody i'm
assuming they're a cat person because i
know i'm a dog person
it's just am i a both person all right
oprah uh
boy she i would be intimidated but then
i think she would just
she would make me relax right off the
bat and we'd be in a cushy couch
together and we'd be like
i think within 10 minutes of hanging out
with oprah we'd be holding hands
you know how when you like hold both
hands with somebody and you're looking
right into their eye having a
conversation i would love to do that
i've never done that with anybody but
oprah would be the person i would have
the
both of her hands in my hands i think my
hands will be in her hands
oh she's in control yeah oh yeah my
hands are in her hands
and my eyes are locked on her eyes and
then maybe
maybe my my head is resting on her bosom
after a couple hours feels like a
connection
uh yes oprah
is a dog person lady gaga
lady gaga like in a get up or without
makeup
cause i asked stephanie yeah definitely
i want i want to connect with her
i've connected with everybody have i not
i believe so
yeah i want to meet her too lady gaga
is a dog person isn't that surprising uh
i know she drives a pickup katy perry
well she
she dated john mayer yeah so is this my
mom
is this my end with john mayer not
anymore no
katy perry is a cat person yeah freddie
mercury
freddie mercury man what a talent
what what a time i mean
i just you know
i think it's one of those don't meet
your heroes kind of thing
i just i think i admire him too much to
meet him so you don't think you would
vibe with him
no freddie mercury is a cat person
you're you're skewing dog right now just
so you know yeah you're skewing dog i'm
skewing dog
i'm not getting rid of my dog though the
rock
uh i
he's tough i just don't know you know
it's
i don't i don't think so the rock
is a dog person and finally
vanna white what a talent
myrtle beach girl um
uh definitely definitely i mean i'd be
strolling on the beach i mean christy
would be there about to say are you in a
relationship with vanna because that's
what it sounded like no
it's just it's a double date situation
it's a triple date because i say jack
there
no because they're not a couple i know
her husband
or whatever what do you think her
husband's like uh
do you think he's known as vanna white's
husband i think it's kind of like a
dolly parton's husband situation
low profile yeah you just don't know
it's like is he covered in tattoos
right i've heard well the rumor is that
dolly's covered in tattoos not her
husband uh i think her husband
really has a lot of tattoos you
definitely connect with vanna yeah yeah
triple date my dad
and uh his wife are also there we're all
strolling down the beach vanna white
is a cat person we're strolling on the
beach with a bunch of cats a bunch of
cats
so what i don't i don't i wasn't keeping
score but
i think maybe that demonstrates that uh
you've got openness to both
i you know it's it's better to regret
something you did than something you
didn't
okay but not having a cat at your house
that you don't you know you know people
that doesn't
really apply to this situation i don't
think people talk about
because once you have a cat you have the
cat cats like for a long time like the
reputation of a cat
even if i hate the cat it's like i have
a i have a first person experiential
knowledge
of of that like i've only heard
all this stuff about cats like i i want
to experience that for myself like i
want to take out a bite out of that pie
it's how is how i feel about i'm like
you know let's just go for it
and see what happens well i don't but do
it responsibly
do it safely yeah yeah yeah i would say
that it is
the one thing that is definitely true in
lilly's presentation is the level of
commitment
is way less like because
your day-to-day with a dog there's just
there's so much yeah there is so much
responsibility
because the dog needs so much the cat
doesn't need as much from you
so i do think that getting a dog that's
a problem if the cat doesn't need me i'm
not going to like it
i will say that yeah but i'd like to
getting a dog that is a problem dog
is a bigger i'm again i'm saying this as
a dog owner that makes sense i think
it's a
bigger responsibility or a bigger pain
in the ass than getting a cat
that's just problem cat that's just
doesn't like you yeah a lot of people
have cats that's like yeah we don't
touch him
we just set the food out he's kind of he
kind of roams around it's like after a
while it's kind of like
okay that's the way that cat is i think
i think stevie's cat is a little like
that but i always see the cat in the
background i i need to talk to her about
it yeah
okay so no final decision
i'll keep you updated and exploit it for
entertainment as much as possible
because that is a
wide silver lining you know for sure
definitely in my profession it's better
to regret something you did to something
you didn't do
i mean what percentage of my
contribution to the entertainment value
of what we do is based on my personal
regrets
i've never thought of that but more than
mine
all right i feel good about that yeah
do you have a wreck oh [ __ ] forgot about
the wreck
um i'm excited about yourself i've told
you about this because i texted you
you know before we weren't watching
survivor one night because everybody
wasn't there and i don't like watching
survivor unless all of the families
there
including the cat and so it was me and
lando and christy and we're like i'm
just like browsing
and it was close to bedtime i was like
we might have time to watch like a
22-minute sitcom
and then i i saw this thumbnail on
netflix
and the runtime of the thing it looked
like a movie but the run time was 16
minutes i'm like
this is strange a 16 minute thing on
netflix like a short film type situation
but i was so drawn in by the thumbnail
of it
that i was like let's watch this it's
short if it sucks it's fine
john was trying to contact aliens that's
what it's called
it's got this guy with long hair and a
long beard and like
i i mean he's got what i would call the
crazy eye
from like the life aquatic with steve
zizu when they talk about that
uh and i'm like this this looks
interesting i
i mean after i watched it i texted you
i know your bedtime's later than mine i
was like i bet you i just knew you would
like it so i
i was like watch john was trying to
contact aliens on netflix it's 16
minutes
you can do it before you bedtime and i
did it in the morning while
i was watching while i was watching
breakfast i was eating breakfast which
is
so i've never watched netflix while
eating breakfast well i was coming in
and i was like
16 minutes and it's probably something
funny to talk about so i'll just watch
it
i think netflix is onto something with
these shorter videos i think
i think they could just have shorter
videos and they could be more
personality based and you look
they should have commenting underneath
and like video replies
so make it youtube yeah uh
it's it's just a like a
an interestingly edited um
by biopic not biopic it's just a
documentary of this guy
john in like the middle of nowhere who
has devoted his entire life to
contacting aliens
um and it's got it's got a couple of
it's got a there's a defining moment in
the documentary
that we are not going to spoil i'm not
going to spoil it the only thing i'll
say
is that while watching breakfast
why am i saying watching breakfast is
that what happens when you watch netflix
while eating breakfast yep
while eating breakfast with my wife
watching this 16 minute
short film when the thing that you're
talking about that we will not spoil
happened
i might i like my eyes welled up with
tears
ah yeah like it was i it was this thing
was 16 minutes long it was touching
it was touching we were giving away too
much already because the the best thing
is to go in totally blind
so forget everything we said except to
watch it yeah
16 minutes of your time that's all we
ask
and you know 100 100 and
well how many how many minutes have we
been going right now sometimes we ask a
little bit less sometimes we have a
little bit more
thanks for being on the journey with us
hashtag biscuits
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best